hello everyone welcome to today's live
panel discussion how should we conduct
and assess teaching and training to
optimize animal handling I'm Brenda
Kelly Kim of laggers and I'll be your
moderator for today's discussion we are
delighted to bring you this panel
discussions presented by lab groups the
leading social networking site for
science professionals for more
information please visit us at WWF com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this talk is designed to
be interactive we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to get to as many of your
questions as you can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation properly please let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right of your presentation
window or ultimately submitting your
problems through the green Q&A button at
the lower left I'd now like to introduce
today's speakers dr. Clough Allison and
dr. Jeffrey Everett plus is an associate
professor at the Department of
experimental medicine the University of
Copenhagen he obtained a master Medical
Sciences about follow University in 2001
where he also graduated as a PhD in
comparative medicine since 2005 boss is
doing research and animal welfare and
model refinements especially with focus
on pain and stress he is also
responsible for his department's
teaching and training activities for
technicians as well as PhD students and
other academics Jeff Everest currently
serves as a director of comparative
biology and medicine glaxosmithkline rd
in Research Triangle Park north carolina
he also serves as an adjunct professor
in the department of pathology at Duke
University School of Medicine he
received his dbm from Cornell University
and then conducted residency and
postdoctoral training at the University
of Pennsylvania and the University of
Illinois he is a member of the American
College laboratory animal medicine and
the american college of veterinary
pathologist
and has served in leadership positions
in both organizations he has led Animal
Care and Use programs and has been an
active advocate for increasing quality
of Animal Care and Use and the
translational relevance of animal models
he is a former council member of the
Institute for laboratory animal research
of the US National Academy I will now
turn it over to dr. Dobson and Everett
for your talk thank you very much Brenda
it is console person speaking and I
would like to welcome you to this panel
discussion I will start by giving a
presentation of around 10 to 15 minutes
just to introduce and bring up some
topics that could be relevant to discuss
and I will focus on two issues where
first of all I will discuss whether or
not and when we need to have live
animals in our education and then I will
turn the focus more on to what we should
teach and how it should assess the
competences and skills in the persons
that we teach but as you know there's we
pretty well agree on that there is a
need for live animals in education for
all persons performing or participating
in animal experimentation in one way or
another and that could be technical
stuff such as animal caretakers lab
technicians and so on and academic staff
such as PhD students postdocs and others
and it is necessary both from our
legislation and regulations in Europe we
have quite strict definitions from the
new directive and I also know that in
the United States there are quite clear
demands for how at least teaching should
be undertaken but we also have a concern
for the animals that we use and this
concerns brings forward and more or less
forces us to actually train the people
that conduct the research and the
experimentation and it is essential for
persons actually performing experiments
to obtain relevant knowledge and skills
in various procedures on animals too
pending on what kind of procedures these
people are working with them but of
course there is a dilemma because we
have a well-recognized desire to reduce
the number of lab animals used including
those used in education so we have a
wish for reduction but we'll also need
to train the staff otherwise we will not
be able to handle the animals properly
and the better trained staff we have the
more refinement will have so what we
want is simply to have highly skilled
personnel that can be trained with a
minimal number of animals and if this
possible well of course this depends on
in which situation if we look at what
students want people who have taken the
previously called philosophy category c
courses in europe which now are referred
to EU functions a B and D or a b c and d
depending on country we remember look at
the course evaluations from these
students and these are students who are
future PhD students or actually PhD
students or even beyond that that shows
that animal handling animal procedures
such as blood sampling injections etc
are among the topics that these students
because it a most important and request
more practicing in and we've shown this
in a couple of studies some years ago
where we scrutinized all course
evaluations from the students that we
had so there were several hundreds in
about five to ten the period of time so
people that are being educated to
perform the Alamo experiment they really
want to practice on animals and of
course they also need to practice on
these animals but the question is when
do they need this and the plus says that
well it's necessary when they need to
train tactile skills when they want to
handle and restrain live animals
regardless if it's a rodent or a rabbit
or a pig or a dog or what kind of animal
it is for if it's a reptile etc etc but
also injections blood sampling and
surgery on living tissue
and many of the procedures such as
injections blood sampling and surgery
and living tissues make can be
supplemented with dummies dummies such
as rubber rats with the tubes inside
that can be used as vessels but they
cannot be completely replaced of course
so you need at some extent animals
within the students to train on but in
some situations when you only want to
observe the animals then for instance
when you do anesthesia monitoring or
when you want to do behavioral studies
when you train animals of the basic
level using live animals is actually
less educational and a huge waste of
animals so in those situations it's
actually more beneficial not to use live
animals but instead using filmed animals
and we have two different exercises that
our department that previously were done
with live animals that we have now
developed video exercises for instead
and this has turned out to be very
fruitful one exercise in anesthesia
where we anesthetized rats with
different compounds and then the
students monitor various parameters that
are relevant for the anesthesia and then
we meet in plain um and discuss these
observations and then that's one
exercising behavior where the students
trained to do a functional observational
battery what we have seen from doing
these video exercises instead of using
live animals which were previously did
is that for each student's there's more
time for observation because the student
can fast-forward and rewind whenever he
or she wants to and all the students are
looking at the same animals so the
discussion about the interpretation will
actually be focusing on the same
observation if you split students into
small groups where each little group and
esta ties their own rats and observe
them you will have quite a variation
between the different animals and that
could of course be good because there is
variation when you anesthetize the
animals but the variation that the
students will see we will be more
related to the stress that the students
induce on the animals rather than than
the actual anesthetic compound so this
has led to more much more fruitful
discussions in plenum
for the anesthesia and for the
behavioral study and in particular what
we have seen is that when the students
do come to a later stage when they
actually anesthetize animals and do
procedures they are more interested in
the anesthesia they pay more attention
to monitoring the anesthesia in the
exercises when the animals are used and
this was actually not really the case
before so we have been using this video
exercises now for the last five to six
years which with great success and with
a lot of animals saved but as I said all
exercises cannot be completely replaced
with video exercises because we need to
have training of tactile skills in live
animals if a person is at one stage
supposed to do procedures in these
animals so one crucial question is how
do we know whether the training works or
not it's one thing to discuss what we
should train but that of course depends
on what the person is going to perform
but how do we assess that this really
works and this is the very difficult
part of the speak because there's no one
single answer that goes for everything
but I will give a suggestion of how we
do it in our department and then you may
ask and or come up with your own
suggestions perhaps of how you do it and
we can take the discussion from there
when we assess practical skills
regardless of whether it's a a
technician or an academic we have two
vital questions first of all what should
we assess and how should we assess
because if you look at the little comic
strip which says algebra class will be
important to you later in life because
there's going to be a test six weeks
from now that it's not the way we want
to assist hours our students we want
them to learn how to train themselves
they should get a basic idea of what
they do but then realize how they should
proceed with the training what we assess
is what that depends on what kind of
procedures we are interested in all the
students are interested in and after our
basic courses that we have
we teach the animals in basic needle and
syringe handling how to handle surgical
instrument and suture in some cloth or
some chicken skin or similar just to
practice and then they do handling and
minor procedures in rats handling and
minor procedures in mice and some basic
surgery and rats and as you can see we
have listed a number of a criteria that
we assess whether they can handle the
needles and syringes correctly can
perform adequate surgical suturing cloth
can handle restrain rat satisfactorily
etc etc and then we simply assess the
the student with other gifts or no and
the tricky part is here because we say
that we assess whether they can handle
and restrain rats satisfactorily and
what does that mean who decides what
satisfactory is and that is their
difficult I will get back to that in the
later and I'll a region later slide so
as I said we score yes or no and this
was something that we discussed a lot
before we went over to this person to
this assessment whether we should have
some scoring system from a grading
system from one to five or one two three
or whether it should be just qualitative
either yes or no and we decided that the
latter case yes or no should be the case
because that would be the most simple so
we simply look at the score sheet when
the student is finished and if there are
too many no's then the student has to
redo the relevant practicals and parties
to complete the course so they had to
come back at a follow-up session where
those who have failed the practicals
redo these practicals so it depends in
and we make a case-to-case judgment
simply one thing there has to be scoring
and that is handling a restraint we will
not let any student or any person who
will perform animal exploitation out of
the room and give them a certificate
unless they can handle and restrain
animals in a way that minimizes the
stress and the animals and so on and
then whether they can do a perfect intra
venus injection in the mouth that is not
really the most important because we
want them to realize that they should
train so we don't have a fixed number of
score yes that has to be achieved we
make a case-to-case judgment we discuss
among the teachers if we are in doubt
and then we discuss with the student to
come up with the best idea so it's a
rather flexible system but since we are
quite many instructors instructors for
each session this has turned out to work
quite fine and when you assess these
students for instance in these basic
courses that we provide to all the PhD
students and scientists and here I focus
on them in this slide because the
technicians the animal caretakers stayed
in Denmark where I work they have to go
through a bit more than three and a half
years of education before they are very
completely completed animal caretakers
but if we look at scientists they take a
three week two to three-week basic
course and of course you don't become an
expert in the techniques practiced when
you when you take a course of this
duration so we need to decide what we
should focus on and instead of assessing
that the person can make a perfect
intravenous injection or some bleeding
technique we focus a lot on do the
students try the very best they can and
do the treaty animals with respect and
do they and this is perhaps the most
important do they show potential of
becoming experts meaning it are they
interested in actually continuing to
learn this so we look at if the students
know the limitations and understand the
need to continue the training throughout
the career and I think this is the key
and I also underlined it here on the
slide that is the key assessment method
that we make or the key learning outcome
i would say that we have that we and we
actually have that as learning outcomes
in in competences from our courses that
they should be able I can quote here
what it's just in our learning outcomes
and the students shall be able to
independent
take responsibility to implement and
further develop practical skills in
handling of common rodents first and
this is the course for rodents so that
is what we put a lot of emphasis on so
we have some discussion time now that
was what I want to talk about as an
introduction and then we have some
topics that we would like to discuss we
can get back to these but i think we
Jeff maybe we should do so that we push
out some of these polls because we have
some polls but you can vote on and tell
us how you are doing it when you train
you can see the first pole coming up
here and that says do you have defined
qualifications for trainers and
Assessors so if you just click and what
the situation is at your Institute
meaning that the persons that train do
they have qualifications
the results we have sixty-three percent
saying yes and it's about 660 240 saying
yes and no so about sixty percent of you
have defined qualification for trainers
and assesses and I think this is very
important to have so that you actually
use people in the training the
instructors that are being used that
they are actually properly trained and
know what they what kind of teaching
they should conceive so that you have
regular meetings and you also train the
persons that are going to train so that
first of all they are good at what
they're teaching but also so that they
know what they should teach and so that
you harmonize about that and Jeff do you
have a comment to this yes so one of the
comments that I've been interested in
looking at is the concept of how you
train for either competency or
proficiency so that that this conference
is about reproducibility and so one of
the questions is how do you train so
that studies have a maximum ability to
be reproduced and replicated within your
facility or between your studies and
that's been extremely important to us at
glaxosmithkline and throughout the
pharmaceutical industry when we look at
challenge studies when we look at rodan
efficacy studies very very basic
procedures such as intra oral gavage and
arm minor injections can really affect
the reproducibility of studies depending
on whether people are trained to you
know minimal competency or whether
they're trained to higher higher levels
of practice which often takes increased
numbers of animals and experience so I'm
very interested in hearing how people
approach that particular question
push the next question class ok so i
push the yeah here is the next poll our
trainers and assesses trained to train
or SS and that is what i mentioned that
that is very important to him so let's
see what what it's like out in the real
world
and here we have almost seventy percent
of you saying that the trainers and
assesses are trained to train or assess
and that is really good I would have
loved to see it an even higher number
but but in my opinion that is very
important that you train them as I said
first of all so that they're good at
what they are teaching and instructing
but also so that you can discuss and
harmonize how you should teach it and
what you should teach so that everyone
agrees I think it's also a very and for
the student it's important to have
instructors that seem to agree on what
they are teaching of course there are
different methods of doing different
things and one made prefer their own way
but if they get too much discussions
between the instructors that that
confuses the students so Harmon so
skills and harmonization is important I
think doctors will comment concerning
that issue come in from an attendee says
in his establishment the trainers are
trained to train but not trained to that
yeah and I think that's that is very
difficult to train someone to assess and
but I think it is as I said previously I
think important is that you sit down and
discuss and decide what is it that you
want to to assess what do you want the
student to learn make very clear clear
learning outcomes so that you know and
in our case may not be a clear learning
outcome because it's quite a fuse but
that is our main goal we want the
students to come out and realize that
I'm not an expert when I have got my
certificate I need to train for the rest
of my career and and how you assess that
precisely is of course difficult but I
think meet regularly with all the
trainers and Assessors and discuss and
sort of push each other to because some
some are very strict and may think they
have to be able to do a perfect
procedure of that or this or that kind
while others are more where we want them
to be more
were self-aware of impulsive training
and find a balance there so n plus 1
comment I would make for many procedures
one of the things that's lacking in the
field at least lacking in the published
literature is um what performance
standard should be so for instance we
all know that um if one gives an IP
injection to our rats or mice there's a
certain percentage of injection that
probably does not go IP and um you know
most of our procedures do not replicate
with a hundred percent fidelity and
there's not good published rates of what
expectations should be for various
levels of proficiency and this is
something that many institutions don't
establish for themselves and how do you
is how do you assess it so in other
words arm for intra oral gavage for
instance arm what would your rate of
intrapulmonary aspiration be for us you
know sailing that that type of thing arm
and this becomes very very important for
replication of studies but there's not
good literature values out there for
what we should expect so I'd be
interested in audience of input into how
they assess that and how they determine
their performance standards for their
institutions and so we should push the
next poll here right
and we have sixty percent sixty-three
percent say no to this so some of you
actually verify the effectiveness but
the majority doesn't and if I understand
you're right Jeff there is a need for
for looking deeper into this and
published more the success rate of how
both both will be trained but also when
it's actually conducted out out in the
laboratories how well we succeed
okay you have to have some other comment
if we have uh the more comment could be
made for various forms of training tools
that are out there um it's not just how
we assess final procedures it could be
assessing the effectiveness of some of
the refinement techniques that we try to
use so in other words when we do replace
live animal a tactile procedures with
cadavers or when we replace live animal
procedures with alternative procedures
how do we assess the effectiveness of
that part of the training because often
we don't completely replace the live
animal training so how do we demonstrate
that you know we in fact have a justice
effective outcome and we've we've
managed to some performance standard not
be interested in commentary on that the
firm do you want to come up on me sure
yeah yeah I think this is a very very
difficult question to ask how we
actually assess that because we don't
know the outcome if we take a PhD
student that we trained basic procedures
we we don't know what goes on when that
we won't let them out until we feel that
this is a person that will actually do
their very best but once they're out
it's a it's their own responsibility and
their labs responsibility to do the CPD
training and then of course we offer
them but we have very little measures to
see what actually goes on and I don't
know we don't have much of a system for
that in in Europe to actually go out and
assess them that that's the authorities
that should do that that goes the NNC
actually doing the experiment as as
their license tell them to do but to see
how well they actually succeed that is
difficult
and because when they are finished with
their training and they come out and do
the experiments their main focus is on
the experiment they want to have their
data to to answer the hypothesis so that
they can write their PhD thesis so that
is very hard for our own technicians I
would say like we trained in house then
it's much more easier because they would
have follow-up we have routinely
training sessions for these for our
stuff and we we follow them each
individual has sort of a scheme that we
follow and we assess their skills and
how they progress throughout the time so
in that case we have a well-established
system but the people who train and go
out and do their their science in their
labs they're very difficult to follow do
you want to come and fern on that yeah
what well I've been uh curious about
this because I remember when I first
joined GSK at GSK we often had a in
certain areas we had a different
standard for using our well-trained
cadre of laboratory animal scientists
that did procedures all the time for
large animals where we had particular
animal welfare concerns due to the
complexity of working with with dogs or
non-human primates or or or are more
complex large animal McCall's yet we
left investigators more on their own
with rodents um assuming that those
techniques were inherently simpler to
conduct but when it comes to the issue
of this conference of reproducibility I
wonder if there's really any difference
between the reproducibility aspect
between rodents or large animal models
so while it might be okay for some types
of mechanistic work if one is truly
trying to assess for instance compound
efficacy or challenge types of that
phase in small groups of animals and
trying to drive down animal numbers as
we refine experimental designs then for
the reproducibility question
the training competency really becomes
extremely important and critical and so
I curious about how people
I think you disappeared there Jeff are
still with us yup come on there yeah mom
we have a next quit sorry you go on and
I think the results of this this poll
show that people the majority of people
are not differentiating between
competency and proficiency which I think
has important ramifications for the
reproducibility question yeah and this
shows how difficult to this with a with
this issue because we should be better
at assessing where the people are highly
skilled or if they're extremely skilled
and whatever but that is very difficult
to do because if you have five people
even though they have harmonized and
trained together they may still assess
one individual student differently so so
this is difficult I had a comment as a
comment here can I take that without
going viu Brenda I'm sorry of course
because what there was a comic book for
basic skills i assessed by looking for
certain specific skills but i haven't
you wanted to go there but i have an
overarching test i ask myself if i can't
get to work tomorrow could i safely ask
the student to take over the animal care
or handle animal handling aspects of my
job if the answer is yes then the
student is competent not necessarily
proficient and he or she pauses I think
there was a good comment because that is
sort of the same way that we assess the
competence the competence in general but
we are still and at at the level of
basic skills or competence and if people
are extremely skilled or not that is
still a difficult issue so for most
cases we were doing quite well with
assessing can I and I think that was a
good comment can I allow these papers
and to take over my job tomorrow if I if
I am ill and then he or she passes
for reproducibility I don't I don't have
the answer there so I don't know how we
should proceed but I think this is
something that we really should look
into it and try to study and put out
some scientific data on how we actually
assess proficiency to improve produces
reproducibility and one of the one of
the outcomes of sort of doing that
assessment might be on how you set up
people to do in vivo studies so in other
words um do you have more people able to
do the two to have minimal competency at
something or do you centralize studies
through cadres of people that have more
continuous application of of those
skills so that they have them at a more
proficient level and that's something
that really comes down to this how the
institution looks at the conduct of the
in vivo study I think unfortunately in
the case of many basic rodent techniques
it's seen as a relatively low skill
technique and that anybody can can do
these techniques with a minimal amount
of training but then the question is
well how reproducible are the results
that are coming out of the studies
because we seem to have a
reproducibility question out there
throughout our studies and I guess the
question I would have is how much of
that reproducibility question is due to
the fact that we don't have people that
sometimes conduct studies and feel very
comfortable in the handling of rodents
I've seen that in my career as
transgenic mouse application became very
widespread there were many many
molecular biologists that would take you
know a few weeks of training so that
they could handle their mice but they
weren't particularly proficient at
handling of mice you know and what does
that mean for the field as a whole yeah
and I think here the question about
continuous professional development is
is very important and just to make sure
that you don't take a basic course you
go out and do your thing in the lab and
they you you come back to some other
compulsory CPD activity and in two years
or so but that you actually train and
get better over and over again and shall
we go over to the final poll perhaps
what did you want to comment more on
this Jeff up so the final poll actually
if do you have consistent criteria for
assessing efficacy of training
and here we have about 50 50 some do
have consistent criteria and some don't
you want to comment on that Jeff I think
it looks pretty good I'm encouraged by
the fact that there seemed to be almost
half after people have consistent
criteria for assessing advocacy training
so I think that truly is a you know an
encouraging type of mark there clearly
there's room for improvement but I think
that is probably greater than we would
have had a number of years ago so i
think i think the the efforts that have
been made in the regulatory arena in
pushing training in and really having
that as an aspect for the quality of
animal care news programs is maybe
starting to show some results what are
your thoughts close yeah i agree with
you owe us i think it's actually good to
see that there are so many as forty
seven percent so and also as you say i
think that if you go back 10 or 20 years
we would not reach that number so let's
hope it continues in that way we have
received and some questions here from
the audience maybe we should move over
to them okay okay Thank You doctors is
obviously a very interesting
presentation lots of interests lots of
comments from our audience they can
submit their questions by clicking on
the Q&A button typing it in and we will
get to as many as we can we already have
several in here our first question what
are your views on using live animals to
teach euthanasia well I can start with
that I think teaching euthanasia is very
essential because whenever you take on
an animal and put that in an
experimental situation you have to be
able to use an
that animal that's part first of all
it's part of the experiment but also you
need to to be able in the situation
where the animal may be subjected to
suffering or distress in one way or
another you should be there and as fast
as possible euthanized animal as a
humane endpoint so you need to train
euthanasia but whether you should use
live animals just to do that I don't
think that would be necessary depends
also some people are doing nothing but
euthanizing animals they euthanize to
kill the mouse and then they take out
organs or just blood or whatever and but
most people who are going now to do more
experiments with different procedures
they can train the euthanasia as part of
the of the other procedures so that it
ends with the euthanasia and I think
that should be done in different ways so
that you train both chemical euthanasia
by various injections but also different
ways of physical euthanasia so that's
important but then if a person is and
it's also important that anyone who is
supposed to kill an animal in a humane
way has to do be able to do it in in the
best possible manner and that that
requires training so but the training
can also be done in already euthanized
animals or for instance if you want to
Train cervical dislocation in mice and
so on so you can't you cannot only train
euthanasia by only practicing on on
their end animals or dummies or so do
you want to comment on that too Jeff
yeah I totally agree with everything you
said clubs and what I would say is that
um this is something that I think has to
be done a little bit case by case it's
usually a mixture I think every
institution has to has to really ask
itself how it can best organize its
needs and utilize animals that are going
to be euthanized for other purposes for
training and you that
and I think that that's what
institutional Animal Care and Use
committees do do they try to make sure
that there's refinement in the training
for euthanasia but it depends on the end
points that are needed as Klaus said you
know if you have to train in
decapitation for instance or in cervical
dislocation and those can be done with
you know cadaver training arm but
there's going to have to be a mixture of
training types and I think that that's
why institutional Animal Care and Use
Committee scrutinized this area so
strongly great we do have a question
yeah we can go to the next question do
you believe that it is always better to
show a video for the students before
going to practical teaching well I can
start with that too I think if generally
yes it's always better to in one way or
another prepare the students and it
doesn't have to be a video it can be a
dummies but you train just to pick up
either you can use these rats that are
made out of rubber and and very nicely
designed with with fake vessels inside
or it could just be a dummy Rath you can
buy a from ikea for for a dollar each or
so and that can be very useful because
most of the students that we train
especially if they're if they are a
master lever level for instance they are
not used to animals most of them many of
the technicians that we trained who
would become animal care tech if they
have been around animals their entire
lives so they all have a different
approach to it but i would say that when
you train people who are not so used to
animals it's very important to prepare
them in one way or another and if you
have procedures that are going to be
done and now it was focusing on the
handling more or less but if you have
procedures like blood sampling or
injections or gavage or whatever then i
would i would say that it it is
beneficial to have some instructional
video that the student can watch
in peace and quiet and see as many times
as he or she likes so I would say
generally yes Jeff I would agree with
that um I think usually it's beneficial
I think obviously it it depends a little
bit you know there's not a
one-size-fits-all depending on the type
of procedure that's being contemplated
but it's it's always good to prepare the
student for what they're going to be
facing and many students are visual
learners and many students to appreciate
that preparation okay we can move on to
the next question lots lots to consider
there we have another question from web
our attendees who wants to hear your
opinion we not all veterinarians have a
lot of experience in aseptic surgery and
some of us have had years of training in
surgery then we asked our P is to adhere
to the strictest of a step surgery
techniques when all they have had is a
few hours of training do we need to
lower our expectations hoping that they
at least implement some aseptic
technique hoping that they will at least
obtain sub pathogenic contaminant levels
yeah we're done once start with that so
that you know it that too is not all one
size fits all I mean I think it's there
are um I personally believe that there
are certainly kinds of surgical
procedures at certain kinds of species
for which investigators are perfectly
suited to be adequately trained with the
right kind of oversight I think there
are other kinds of procedures that
really do require a much higher level of
a sepsis proficiency and it's not one
size fits all and this is also something
that I think has been recognized by a
lack and others in the regulatory
environment um and that's why there are
distinctions
oh you know what constitutes adequacy of
the surgery I do think it is important
though arm that there be that there be
high level of application of oversight
of surgical procedures and I do think
that many institutions don't properly do
the oversight of investigators that are
conducting surgery and I think that on
this is an area where I acocks really
should have active involvement is
stopping in and routinely over citing
what is going on in areas where surgery
is being performed and where there is
risk for a for septic outcome yeah I
agree with your deaf and so a lot of
case to case judgment we are we are
struggling quite a lot with that to get
our and pis and scientists and our
department to actually want the entire
faculty to work with SF seized during
survival experiments because it is
possible to do it both in rats and mice
which I work with the most and but I
think there is a reluctance see to work
aseptically because it's it gets much
more demanding when you do it there the
investigator may be really skilled in
performing the very procedure that they
do the organization or whatever they do
but the procedure around if the
something that you need to train you
need to train to think aseptically and
that is something where we have to go in
and and help them out so I think you're
I don't know if you should lower your
expectations but I think that you should
at least have the expectations that they
should implement a safety techniques
most most often especially when it comes
to survival surgery and long-term
terminal Sergio and when the animal is a
nest eyes for perhaps more than six or
eight hours because they there are some
publications showing that
subclinical infections actually we will
start affecting the outcome of the
experiments one of the things that many
institutions don't do adequately is
assess outcomes so if you leaped up to
investigators to monitor their own
surgery they're often not adequately
assessing the outcomes in optimal ways
and so even determining when animals are
actually having you know having septic
outcomes can be challenging unless
there's an active program of monitoring
for that and more and more as we get
into more sensitive ohmic outputs I
think that we're going to find that
subclinical effects are going to really
be affecting our reproducibility of some
of the outcomes that we have okay you
have another question on attendee asks
our training videos commercial or are
they recorded during expert
demonstrations about larger animals and
aquatic animal well the videos that we
are using those we have made ourselves
from where we set up a homemade studio
and at a two day of shooting but I think
there may be commercially there are
commercially available exercises of
different kinds but i can't say i don't
have an overview of it right here now so
i don't know about you Jeff do you have
any idea where to find I think you have
to go out I think it depends on the type
of thing you're training for and what
kind of institution you're in there are
commercially available or training
materials and training videos that can
be purchased and you you know I hate to
say but many investigators obviously go
to you know the internet and go to
youtube and go to journal of visual
experimentation and
many um I don't want to say dubious
sources because there aren't necessarily
dubious videos out there with poor
technique but you have to make sure that
what it is you first have to establish
what it is you're training for and what
your training standard is going to be
and often to get the specificity to your
personal institutional SOP or training
standard you might have to create that
that video customized but but it is
possible to obtain just about anything
commercially now I say we have a comment
that's coming in from an attendee he
says for studies using small numbers of
procedures in small numbers of animals
we're opposed to getting the researcher
to perform the procedure for the
following reason if we if we do minimal
training there are concerns about
confidence proficiency repeatability etc
but if we do lots of training we
consider that we are wasting animals our
approach for those small studies is to
have a single very proficient person
usually a member of the technical staff
who performs the procedures on behalf of
the researchers this is closed I think
that's a quite quite sound approach
actually because it is very important to
have some person who who does the
procedure has to be skilled because
otherwise it will be so much variation
and but of course it's also hard to have
one person because if this person gets
ill or something happens then that can
affect this study quite a lot so if you
have a as someone who is proficient then
maybe this someone should be a couple of
or a small group but otherwise I think
it's a it's a quite good approach
actually but it also depends on what
kind of sorry exists it also depends on
what kind of study we are dealing with
because and you have to judge Peckham
case the case as well
condom yeah class I would like to take
on to cut 2 comments they came across
and just um make note of them one I
didn't want something to be taken out of
what I said um there are some terrible
materials out there in the public sector
on the Internet ok so I'm not advocating
anybody goes out to get their training
on on on the Internet necessarily I mean
just like you know you're not going to
go on the internet to watch a surgical
procedure and then go do the surgical
procedure things need to be vetted very
very carefully by the institutional
Animal Care and Use Committee and by the
attending veterinarian of the
institution arm but i would say that
there are many sources of good video
instructional materials that are
available and there's also the lab
animal welfare training exchange oh
lawdy there are organizations out there
now that are creating materials so
there's more and more access to
materials that you may not have to
create your own videos in house that's
all I meant to say with my comment
before yeah there was a comment coming
in here also saying i have seen
surgeries in internet and i'm horrified
by what I've seen and that is I mean
that may be true if you go just look up
some procedure on YouTube you have no
idea of whether that procedure is done
correctly or not but I think you can
scrutinize the internet and then our
talk to colleagues right to people that
you trust in enough have you seen this
do you have something to recommend
because you have to judge that from case
to case definitely we do have another
question attendee asks what are your
thoughts on how often a skill needs to
be performed on an animal to remain
confident well that also depends on what
kind of procedure but i would say
repeated continuously is necessary and
you some procedures you can learn fairly
quickly to perform in a good manner but
if you stop doing it for some months or
half a year then you have to start
retraining it
if you are working with microsurgery
that I used to do seven years ago so
then you have to really you have to
train for six months before you actually
start the procedure well go plus minus
amount but but you really have to tre
extensive trained extensively otherwise
you may actually look into the effects
of what the surgery done rather than
their the hypothesis that you were
interested in and as so if you don't do
that repeatedly and continuously you
will you will lose I mean you always
have it in your backbone so you can
start up and doing it but you won't
doing it regularly so for some
procedures you really have to train all
the time for some reason procedures like
blood samplings you may have to do with
repeatedly every other month or so yep
do you want to comment more thoroughly
totally agree it's procedure dependent
and much more than anything else and I
do think that even things that we think
are relatively simple kinds of
procedures I worry that if people don't
perform them on a relatively continuous
basis that it affects reproducibility on
studies it often depends on the type of
studying the type of endpoints that
we're being looked at as well as the
type of procedure okay thank you we have
a comment in here from an attendee about
some excellent resources perhaps you and
Klaus could speak about those yeah this
one person recommended to two persons
recommending things coming from the
National Center of 30 at the UK NC 3r
Center especially from Paul Fleck nails
lab I know Paul well and they do really
good exercises and practicals in pain
and the pain assessment and similar so
that I can but I just don't want to go
out and generally recommend everything
because before I would use anything I
would like to see it and I also like to
see
before I just recommend it but that is a
good source i would say because there
are people who know what they are
dealing with who put out those most
videos and similar yeah i would also
like to remind people that training is
ultimately under you know the auspices
at least in the United States of the
institutional Animal Care and Use
Committee and there is a reason to have
committee discussions of training
materials and training approaches and so
it's something to you know keep in mind
training really should be in many
respects centralized under I cook
auspices and not just left laboratory to
laboratory and large institutions so I
think that becomes important as well
thank you for coming to just about the
end of our time I'd like to turn it back
over to you vote for any final comments
or other information that you have for
our attendees and no I'm well the final
conclusion is and I think I think Jeff
actually said that the training is
something that you have to do repeatedly
and continuously and depending on what
procedure you are working with you have
to adapt the training to that I think
that never be a quick concluding remark
otherwise I don't have so much
information i think this presentation
and then discussion will be available
online forum also after this is that
right printer that is press that's great
and if you have some questions that you
come up with oh I should have asked that
you're welcome to to contact me by email
I don't know if my email is available
but maybe you could make it we can take
care of asking your brother excellent
care that
Oh Jeff any concluding remarks from you
know I'd like to thank people for their
input and also just leave a as a
concluding comment I think that the
issue of training in the handling of our
research animals is probably one of the
things that we can really do to augment
quality of our programs I think that
just basic handling arm makes all the
difference in many many types of
procedures and training often makes the
difference in how we handle our animal
great thank you so much like to thank
Klaus adjust for their time today our
participants and our attendees for their
interesting common questions and as
close mentioned today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August of 2016 attendees that we're here
today will receive an email from labrada
learning them when it's ready and
watchable and we'd like you to format
forward that email to any colleagues who
may have missed today's live
presentation also questions that get
sent in during the autumn to replay will
go to close or Jeff and we can get back
with you on questions that you have that
we didn't get to thank you again dr.
Everett and appleton for coming today to
our attendance attending audience for
their excellent questions we hope you
see you next time good bye bye bye thank
you thank you